you said if parties maybe look beyond
their own narrow party agenda and do
what's best for the country and for me a
Scottish conservative leader what would
be best is if we see the grip that the s
p has on Scotland at the moment is
loosened so is that your priority to see
the SMP weakened even if it means labor
your other rival significantly benefits
well that answer was actually given to a
question you know what do you think
about Anna salwar and Scottish labor not
agreeing with this so either the same
Scottish labor as they have done in the
past have refused to accept that getting
rid of the SMP is the best thing for
Scotland so I was focusing on that and
the other point that you've not quoted
yet you've put it a lot what I've said
you didn't quote the line that says I
will always encourage Scottish
conservative voters to vote Scottish
conservative because in many seats
across Scotland we are the main
Challengers to the SMP and if supporters
of other parties can unite behind us
then we will defeat the SMP in many
seats across the country no I I saw that
line as well I watched the the video
back of the of the interview as well to
to have it in context as well as the the
words on the page and I guess the
question then is is why did you say
contradictory things uh that that you
know our contrary to to that line of
saying you want people to vote Scottish
conservatives because you also said to
try and ensure that the s p have big
losses at the next general election the
public know how to tactically vote I
mean that is a pretty clear hint that
you're saying one thing but you mean the
other that you're happy for Scottish
Tories to vote labor if necessary no
suggestion you were saying I'm speaking
to you live here in Murray Murray was uh
before I won the seat in 2017 had been
an SMP seat since it conservative
previously won in 1983 the year I was
born but we won it in 2017 and we've
retained it in 2019 because voters from
other parties united behind us here in
Murray to defeat the SMP at the time it
was at the seat held by the smps
Westminster leader Angus Robertson and
many people thought it would be
impossible to remove the SMP here in
Murray but we did that because people
could see that we were the party to get
behind and that's the same in many seats
across the north the Northeast the south
of Scotland in parts of the central belt
like Easter where we are the key
Challengers to the SMP
which I totally get and obviously that's
an example of where you guys beat the
the SMP but I'll just go back to that
line I just read you I wonder whether
you you want to withdraw it now or yeah
you said the public know how to
tactically vote so
conservatives are the best party either
holding the sea or as the main rival to
the SMP it's up to other parties to
decide on the approach they're going to
take in the seats that they're targeting
but I'm speaking about the seats that
the Scottish conservatives have won in
the past can win again in the future and
are the main Challengers to the SMP and
we have a sophisticated electorate here
in Scotland and they want to see in many
cases the SMP removed and you do that
and these seats by supporting this
Scottish conservatives and that will
move us away from this focus on
Independence above all else that you get
from the SMP to have a real focus on
people's priorities which is supporting
the NHS boosting our economy improving
our educational system these are all the
priorities that people across Scotland
have not another Independence referendum
uh it's it's interesting that you're
you're being so clear about wanting to
remove the SMP both in this interview
and in your comments to to the telegraph
I mean do you do you have a very real am
I exaggerating am I reading too much
into this a real animosity towards them
well I think they want to divide our
country we've done that for the last 16
years Nicholas sturgeon herself said on
key issues such as our drug test she had
taken her eye off the ball because she
was constantly focused on Independence
and another referendum we don't Hamza
Yusuf is a continuity candidate he has
continued where Nicholas sturgeon left
off he said he wants to have another
Independence referendum he asked for the
powers in the first phone call that you
had with the Prime Minister and he has
um created a post of Minister for
Independence so I think if we can remove
the SNP and take that Focus away from
another Independence referendum and put
it exactly where the public humans
thought wanted which is improving their
Public Services then Scotland can
benefit from that
I'm I mean I'm interested that that
becomes the priority to to weaken the
SMP and I wonder whether you think that
Scottish voters can trust kirst armor
and labor in Scotland because it was
quite recent when David Cameron LED your
party that the opposite argument was
made that a vote for labor was
essentially a vote uh for Nicola
sturgeon and the s p and a move towards
greater and a further move towards
another Independence referendum so again
there seems to be a contradictory
element to this that you're suggesting
now voters can trust the labor Vision in
Scotland if that's what's necessary to
remove the s p well I'm focusing on what
the Scottish conservators can do and the
Scottish conservators maximizing our
presence and returning more MPS helps
Rishi sunak as prime minister staying in
number 10 in a conservative government
continuing to govern for the whole of
the United Kingdom and actually what
people in Scotland want it's the two
governments working together they want
Scottish and the UK governments to
develop policies and work together to
improve the lives of people in Scotland
but she soon acts first visit into
Scotland was up to Inverness to announce
one of the two freeports that the
statute government Scottish and UK
governments working together to develop
and introduce Freeport so I think that's
what Scottish people want to see more of
the government's working together and
focused on the issues that really matter
to them
in in terms of another line I just
wanted to pick up on you mentioned if
parties look beyond their own narrow
party agenda and do what's best for the
country uh was was one of the lines do
you think that that's not what happens
in the UK does your uh conservative
party boss if if that's uh maybe there's
not a direct reporting line which is
maybe why we've got to all of this but
but do you think that Rishi sunak
doesn't do that already uh or is he only
governing for conservative voters well
again I I did actually answer this
question at the start when you asked me
earlier that was in response to your
question about Scottish labor saying
they were not interested in this Anna
sour decided it was more important for
the SMP to hold on to these seats and
the conservatives winning in many of
these seats back or challenging the SMP
in many areas of Scotland so that's
where that remark came from it was an
answer to that question
how many seats would be a success uh at
the next general election for the
conservatives even on Easter Sunday but
I'm very happy at home here I'm not
going to get into this uh debate
continual debate about what's her
success or otherwise I want to see the
Scottish conservatives yeah I mean team
in the seats we've got and progressing
because that can help keep your issue
soon after number 10 in a conservative
government delivering for Scotland and
the UK and and in terms of clearly you
are the leader of the Scottish
conservatives and we know you're
passionate about keeping Scotland within
the United Kingdom what is your personal
priority uh between uh keeping the
conservatives and currently of course
Russia sunac in number 10 and keeping
Scotland uh as part of the Union yeah
well we can do both because Russia sunak
has been very clear that he doesn't want
to see Scotland divided with another
Independence referendum despite both
Nicholas sturgeon and Hamza Yusuf now
asking to hold another referendum but
she soon act has been absolutely clear
the priorities of people across Scotland
right now are for the two governments to
work together on the major challenges
we're feeding here in Scotland and
across the UK and I'm fully supportive
of the Prime Minister in his efforts to
do that and the way he's governing the
country for the whole of the United
Kingdom was he or any of his team in
touch with you today nope yeah and
fairness I've been out in a farm doing
an Easter egg hunt but none of them have
tried to get in touch
um okay well that that's uh we'll take
take your word for that just uh quickly
I also wanted to mention a quote that
we've we've just received from Jackie
Bailey uh Scottish labor MSP of course
as as you know and uh saying uh she said
this is a desperate move by Douglas Ross
and the Tories who simply want to shore
up votes in the seats they currently
hold she went on to say it's up to
voters to decide which party they want
to support we do not have any deals with
any party in Scottish labor will work
hard to earn the trust and votes of
everyone across the country I guess my
question on that is broadly your
response but all in all whether you've
clarified exactly what you meant
um when you spoke to the telegraph do
you regret saying some of those things
which uh which have clearly allowed this
this Gap to open up as to whether or not
you are advising Scottish voters to vote
tactically well I think the the response
I've seen already in my mailbox today
looking at my emails is people want to
see this they want at where voters don't
support the SMP and then continuing in
power and not focusing on the priorities
of people across Scotland they want to
hear Party leaders
urging people to get behind their party
and the seats Fair they are the
strongest party and that's what I've
been seeing here in Murray and in other
parts of the country therefore we hold
these seats and where we're looking to
make gains and of course Jackie Bailey's
response comes from a party that when I
last suggested this back in 2021 had a
similar response in Scottish labor lost
seats and votes say Scottish
conservatives maintained our 31 and we
increased our votes for the Hollywood
elections I think that tells you
everything that the public needs so but
I agree with Jackie Bailey ultimately it
is up to the public they will decide and
at the moment we are hearing the public
crying out for a change the status quo
here in Scotland they don't want to see
the SNP in power they want to see
politicians representing them that
reflect their views not simply obsess
over Independence really sorry to go
back and labor the point but you based
he just encouraged tactical voting again
you just said they want to see leaders
of their party encourage people to vote
for that party where they are strongest
yes and that's what I've said not not in
every seat where you where you might
well lose but you would help the s p by
pushing your conservative voters to vote
for conservative well again I I answered
this earlier and I said it's up to other
parties to decide how they approach the
election in the seat sale targeting I'm
telling you in the seats that the
Scottish conservatives are targeting we
can maintain what we've got we can make
games here in Scotland that supports us
about the ones you're not targeting how
many are you targeting
you ask me about numbers earlier than I
said I wasn't going to give oh yeah are
you targeting every single seat because
if you're not your implication is that
you're happy for people to vote labor
and the ones you're not targeting my
implication is very clear that as I said
in black and white in the telegraph I
will always urge Scottish concept of
Voters to vote storage conservative but
in seats that we hold and we can gain
then people know that the unite behind
us are Scottish conservative P can see
an acmp NP removed and the focus staying
away from Independence onto their
priorities